PROFESSOR: OK.
So at this point, we have
our roller ball demo.
Now, we would like to
interface with the Kinect.
To do this, we're going to
use the simple Kinect Unity
package.
It's over here.
So in the simple Kinect
package there is a prefab.
You can drag this
prefab into your game
and it will initiate the Kinect
and do all the stuff that's
required for that.
So now, when I start my game,
the Kinect will turn on.
And it's not going
to do anything yet
because I haven't interfaced it.
So, now I want my ball
that we created previously
to follow my right hand sign.
So what we're going to
do is go into our player
and we're going to add a script.
The script that we're going
to add is the follow join.
You can find it in
scripts, no, Kinect stuff.
There it is and follow join.
So let's drag it
on to our player,
and then we need
to fill out which
object we would like to track.
So in this case I'd like
to follow my right hand.
And you can find that I have
a right hand object here.
So you can drag this right
hand object into the player
controller script.
So that's the tracked object.
And now the ball should
follow my right hand.
So you can see it
there in the scene.
As I move my hand
closer to the Kinect,
it moves closer to the camera.
In many gamines, this isn't
what You'd want though.
So inside that
follow join script
there is an to
invert each access.
Since the z-axis is one
goes toward the camera,
in this case, we're going
to invert the z-axis.
So now, when we click play,
as I move my hand forward,
the ball moves forward
within the world space,
and back, left,
right, up, down, etc.
So now, with my right hand,
I can control the ball.
All of the pick-ups should
still work as they did before
and the game can still be won.
So I'm getting all the
pick-ups with my right hand.
Have to go back it up a little.
It's just like using a mouse
or arrow keys, but in 3D.
So as you can see,
that still works.
Your turn.
So now, let's say we
want to track something
other than our right hand.
You can adjust this in
the moving object parent.
So I have a detect joint
script attached to here
and this has a
track joint option.
You can change this to
be any joint you like.
So let's say I want
to do my left and.
I'll select the hand left
object, which is somewhere.
There it is.
And then, for the sake of
making things make sense,
rename my object to
left hand object.
So now that this is
called left hand object,
we want to make sure that the
object attached to the player
controller, follow join, is
indeed the left hand object
as is visible right here.
So now when I click play, it
should follow my left hand
not my right hand.
If the Kinect can find me.
There it is.
And so I can move my
left hand forward,
left, right, up, down, etc.
So now, let's say we want
to try multiple joints
at the same time.
This whole moving objects
parent part can be duplicated.
So Control D or
Command D to duplicate.
And we can now create a left had
object and a right hand object.
So let's go back to being
hand-right and rename this.
So I'm going to add
another sphere to my scene
in order to have another
object for my game.
So let's create a sphere.
And then I'm going it so that
my right hand follows this one
since my left hand already
follows the player.
So in Kinect stuff, follow join.
Drag it right on to that sphere.
OK.
So now, I want this to
follow my right hand object,
so I'm going to drag that
in as my track joint.
And now that sphere should
follow my right hand,
while the other follows my left.
So I didn't set the
invert option on that one
though, so as I
move forward, they
each go in opposite directions.
But otherwise, left and
right work as you'd expect,
and up and down.
So let's say I want to
try a different joint.
Like, let's make my left
hand object be my head.
We'll go to that
moving object parent ,
change it to head here.
And let's rename this to head.
Now, my right hand
controls the sphere
that we just added and my
head controls the player.
So, where is my right hand?
There is my right hand.
Where is my head?
Can we see it?
Can I get it in?
It's down here.
You can see it up on scene view.
I'm struggling to get bearings.
Oh, I never set invert axis.
That would explain that.
Probably going to--
It was on player, right?
No, it was not.
It was on the sphere.
Hope I can re-enter
myself in world space.
There it is.
So, as I move my head left
and right, up and down,
and my hand, they
all go properly.
Each object's position can be
addressed by other objects.
And so this is how you can
gather your data to use however
you like.